hey hey dude tank top monday it's it's
guns out sun's out monday its cons out
sun's out monday got the guns out
there's cat Oh Thank You cat
get your outside acai bowl yeah thanks
for the tennspeed coffee
so your dad looks like a movie star like
a comfort like a Jackie Chan stuntman
movie star does he yeah he's kind of a
rugged looking dudes a good-looking dude
yeah
long hair very long hair he's always had
this like really long rat tail for as
long as I can remember he had like the
Jackie Chan hair cut it here and then he
has the long run you still have cats
stories you liver-spotted [ __ ] come on
man no I just because I follow I came
upon yeah I came upon it now now let me
ask you this about pops yeah what does
he do he looks at is he is he he's a
stout man kind of a thick strong man
he's like me he has like a short stocky
built he works in construction okay
he likes to get his hands dirty by
stronger strong yeah words work strong
fast he working right now uh yeah he's
actually he works a lot of really odd
construction jobs so right now he some
for some reason like before Corona
happened he was working in Oklahoma and
so that's why he sent me that picture
he's like I'm blending in wigglers
Oklahomans am building 5g towers and
[ __ ] the thing is is uh right now with
everything like yesterday when I was
driving there like there was
construction on the 10th now would be
the time to do construction now it'll be
right that would be it so I just as
they're doing construction on both sides
of the tent yeah that makes sense that
makes a lot of things about five g1000
no v GL what a [ __ ] Corona I think you
dump Rhona kid I thought I think you you
called it I think that America is
getting mighty restless right now I
think what's gonna happen is literally
May 15th I really I've already seen this
I'm down in I was down in Venice I was
biking riding my bike and biker and on
the club well um Venice is a strong
chapter so you were the wrong colors
down there Papa well because I might be
because I'm thin boy thin
beats crews then boy beat screws so you
know you're in the slice Club where the
same boy comes to you the gay boy bites
good we call it the thin boy coaster so
it's it's a Chinese are us then you look
at the captive gays don't know we're the
thin boy thi and and help too much
applause marking where the thin boy
coasters hurt and you guys ride by and
go ahead well well it's funny because as
I was down on Washington Boulevard in
the beach as I'm riding my very gay well
my very sort of its way it's a beach at
one speed there's a once it's a beach
cruiser in fact the guy looked amigos
that at one speed I go okay yeah dude I
guess it's a 100 feet cruisers are
though okay it's like a mime for Mongols
Mongol California Chapter they shut off
their joys
there's just hey no they did not really
oh that's surprised no except for - well
no the Mongols acknowledge or think bad
job believe that in Venice I don't
believe that the Mongol bike while you
were sick though huh oh yeah those go
right there they're thick rough looking
guys just hanging those sitting on their
bikes polished very well usually at the
whaler they were across from the whaler
oh well know that Calvin that's that's
right that tells that they were across
from cows and they would they were at
that other bar cross and they were just
sitting not even there on the street
just having sip and look that look like
sipping out of hot paper cups you go
like this
hey boys sweet bikes mmm you're getting
dirty and yellow boy I sure didn't know
I did feel like I was like hey as I rode
by like these men on their bikes and I'm
on my beasts cruiser and I I glanced
over and then I looked away because I
just fell of course she I felt like I'm
not gonna felt like a bit of a [ __ ]
yeah I'm aware I'm gonna do salute him
hey guys my beach cruiser that should be
the theme of your bike club well a suck
yeah yeah well [ __ ] I don't need you
being a moment don't be the head of my
marketing Pro beach communities rocky
beach cruisers and dick sucks
let us sakya fin boy will come to you
fin boy coaster club yeah let's suck you
in boy coaster club while you relax let
us sake well suck yeah and then just put
we take the easy road we take the back
road huh
we take
backroad we take mud don't scare us look
just yeah a little mud never hurt
anybody I mean you're like this covered
in mud that's all spit ball yeah
now it's grease the boys up why don't
you grease the wheels I'm not doing that
hjälsta bites no I'm the promise in 53
mold so the problem is what I told you
well I realized when I was getting off I
realized I was getting older when gay
men stopped looking at me that's when
you know you go oh there's couple twinks
still take you for a ride old man
maybe daddy maybe they got a daddy yeah
there's no daddy compound but it's rich
slim to vanish all right no I think you
should go to the right club dude I can
pay bills there are guys that'll open up
oh yeah I'm Stan open that peach right
well shaved up the well shaved up here
comes a boy bike club you light up your
ass and and and I and I demand my
whistle be clean I demand because I may
be the president of the thin boys
coaster Club you're really pushing this
hey but you got a hey you need to go to
the Abbey and just see how things go
ride your gay beach cruiser up there and
just kind of have a positive attitude
wet your lips and see how the night goes
just be a guy I don't know if the abbeys
closed during coronation give a [ __ ]
about this no they beat Daisy give me
this I don't know dude Kat knows what
I'm talking about
why would she know well she knows she
reads kind of like you need it I need it
so I need so nice up here
I need a bit past Syrian passage of time
just so the Tigers the heat got to eat
cows just here you open up the door she
read yeah yep I mean help did you watch
last dance up so it's four and five I
haven't yet that I will don't tell me
what's so frustrating
I know we all know what happens yeah
mister don't only does he retire huh
does he win
I will get on that immediately you you
really need to I do what's interesting
is and it's gonna be the next episode
spoiler alert Michael Jordan's dad dies
yeah that's that's why I retired
murdered murdered but when you look into
it so suspect I went down
Oh down a weird rabbit hole last night
there was the rumor that gambling debt
butts Michael Jordan and he sells
millions and millions of Michael Jordan
shoes so I don't think money would be an
issue especially if there's a bounty on
his dad's head but it's just really
weird the murders there it's two teenage
kids who killed his dad who pulled over
on the side of the road in North
Carolina there's a hotel like 50 yards
up why didn't stay there who knows and
these two kids are there in prison for
life for it one of the kids says we were
working for someone
they said he was shot in the chest
there's no bullet hole in his shirt
they take the evidence of the shirt
someone on the case buries the shirt in
the backyard the attorney goes the [ __ ]
you doing or they go no it stopped it
stunk in the office so I buried it so
you dig it up get it the [ __ ] back to
forensic man what are you doing is my
bat returns a shirt now there's a gun
wound in the shirt one of the kids who
the one who did murder him says he's
working for somebody else but then his
dad is the share for that County Jesus
Christ the other kid who's on for life
he he goes this is what happened I
believe him another kid's suspect he
goes so my friend called me it's his
best friend called me two young black
kids call me just hey I just killed this
dude I need help hiding the body come
help me so he goes and helps so the kids
that killed his dad were black yes okay
so they killed him he helped him dispose
the body in the in the swamp or whenever
put it over there
and in North Carolina the maximum you
can get your your the maximum years you
can get is 10 if you're you know aiding
and abetting yes
aiding in a murder but they gave him
life so he's trying to appeal that I
don't think she get life and he was no
he's hiding a body so but they got
Michael Jordan's and be a all-star ring
off their dad and something else and
these idiots made a rap video two days
later in the ring and the other [ __ ] are
you kidding
here's what's weird though tell me this
way and you and I aren't really
conspiracy thirty guys besides this
Kovacic here's the thing flattering lot
of hash tag fighters and no but the
thing is Eddie's right but the thing is
don't jump for president to jump
hey so but just kidding the weird thing
is is his dad was missing for 20
one days before then reported miss I
know I remember it was his birthday
seven days later the family didn't
report a misfit enjoying us he was a
lone Luffy always disappeared on his own
it's like you might have I mean it's on
your collar they it you're honest it's a
shame but it's just so it's so
interesting and what else interesting in
Episode five and six last night I think
that's it one two three four five and
six was uh you know Jordan for his
gambling started taking a lot of heat in
the media and he said that's one of the
reasons retired he just don't like the
negativity coming at him and I text my
with outside go dude if he thought this
was rough think about the players today
dealing with social media and then Jay
made a good point he was yeah but
today's players are a little soft and
they're very very emo like Kevin Durant
they care about people's opinions Jordan
doesn't and Kobe came up in social media
age and he didn't give a flying [ __ ]
eating gave a flying [ __ ] Michael Jordan
Jordan address they said gambling
problem egos game problems when your
children can't eat because you're
spending money i guarante I promise you
my children eat very very well I don't I
don't just I mean I don't agree with
that I mean you have a problems they'll
be able to hide in gambling much money
yeah Steve's never stopped gambling I
still don't yeah all of them um I like
you too when it with his shoe so they
wanted him to support this governor I
think in North Carolina a black governor
beating a racist white guy maybe when
you support for that for this guy he's a
Democrat and he goes why would I do that
Republicans buy shoes too
Wow yeah he was like Jim Brown he is I
never wanted to be I'm trying to be a
role model I'm not trying to in my souls
play basketball still shoes dude yeah
that's that's his right that's it Roger
yeah hehe Jim Brown was very critical I
watched humor Jim Brown
I watched him debate a racist governor
and Jim Brown man was marca yes he was
smart and and he was amazing in a lot of
ways I mean Jim Brown took his role very
very seriously well is that a quote when
Ali came out it was him and Muhammad Ali
yes it was both of them and what an
avoid being political back then you know
you you you were basically a second
there as well as much anger yes this
thing was much different than what
Jordan and you remembered
you remember Jim Brown and then
remembered not being able to vote being
you know secre different time yeah
different I don't think that should rely
on Jordans shoulders to kind of pick
Democrat Republican I don't think it's
coming I I think it's I think you are
allowed to say I'm an athlete and I stay
out of that I think I think to be as
great as Jordan it was the only thing
you could do right I mean at least for
him I don't know what to I don't know
what it takes to be that great but I
would imagine it takes dedication show
they've showed like you know he's him
getting off the bus him going to the
hotel him after games him before games
spent time with kids with cancer just
the amount of pressure us put up in the
the notoriety and the fame I don't think
there's been a thing even closest famous
as him not even even with what he get to
deal with I'm I felt I know a hotel and
he was laying down he's like this is the
only time I get just to feel somewhat
normal yeah he goes I stay in here all
day
speaking of greatness like when you have
to be that great so Dan Gable who went
to went to the Olympics and didn't have
a point scored against him won a gold
medal beat all the Russians didn't have
a point scored against it's never been
done it's crazy and Dan Gable that was
the Olympics when the Israeli Olympic
team was a was killed or go by it was
killed by the by the by the Palestine
then been an athlete gonna help them out
there you go and Dan Gable was so
focused on his match that when they said
what did you think of the Olympics he
said or what did you think he said that
you a she said that he said I just did
the weather seemed a little it was a
little foggy so that my joints weren't
they were like and he he didn't even
that was the last thing he was thinking
about last thing he was thinking about
and he said he said that was just
singular focus he was just so focused on
that that he wasn't able to you know so
I don't again I'm not going to criticize
Michael Jordan for being that singular
about it but even drawing was like gods
exhausted mentally I was exhausted and
then they showed the cameras like man
there's never been a guy like Jim ever
ever yeah I mean change culture from
from shoes to hip-hop I mean everything
he was the great one was the most famous
man of all time
name a more famous person the only one
who might compete
Hitler was Muhammad Ali Ashley was
Ashley I don't think so
the clothes right yeah Wally Muhammad
Ali twirled while he even in Africa
remember you saying with Jordan yeah and
so what what Ali said was everywhere you
see a light as you fly over a city they
know I know and I think the same thing
is close I think I think Jordan even it
was bigger because basketball was big
more people can relate to that than
probably probably I would imagine I
don't know how many people in China at
the time or Russia at the time were
watching nominally then when when Jordan
went to Olympics and the dream team it
it just changed dynamics then you know
inspired all you know now in europe in
sweden yet some of the best basketball
players in the world he meant all the
guys from europe and all that that area
that are in the NBA now yeah but he said
he this would make him look like an
[ __ ] I don't think that's fair I
don't think of him as an [ __ ] I think
of him as passionate Jordan like I think
of mezack and such a fierce competitor
and passionate yeah unless see that's
why I saying that last night watch it
when my I told my grandma I don't use
words can make me read it maybe the next
episodes that shows them but I don't I
don't see yet I think he did didn't you
tell me he punched and he punched not
ever do will Purdue okay I love Steve
Kerr to is we're doing punched yeah but
you know again the guys who are this
serious about winning and this
passionate you know I the big thing on
them to not that anybody's gonna side
with Isiah Thomas but you know they
hated Isiah Thomas oh the rumor was
Jordan was I got because they you know
before before the dream team the
Olympics for the USA was all collegiate
players so they weren't they were
amateurs then go and compete with these
pros and we were getting destroyed so
then America went that ain't cool win
send our best so they assembled the
dream team so they called Jordan first
the rumors joint said on me and as long
as Isaiah's nothing yeah what was that
about no hate hate him they hated them
because he had issues with everybody
magic he had issues you know with
Scottie he had issues with I said Isaiah
had issues with all of them so they said
he would mess up the dynamics of the
team so the rumor is although George
said it's not through him but Jordan
said they called me and the first thing
he says he implicated that he goes the
person who you think is not on the team
and gentleman I'm in what he was I don't
have to say anything I didn't do
anything so he goes he can say whatever
he wants here's what I he was I
saying anything they brought to my
attention I saw Isiah Thomas recently at
a party he is not much taller than me
he's not a tall guy to be that great you
know leave with those guys it's best
point gorgeous legs Matt Johnson is that
right oh yeah that good oh yeah
goddamn what might take allen iverson
all those people love I said there's a
great I do love well he's a great
because he wasn't liked as a coach of
the New York Knicks though how
interesting so they just didn't get
along
yes everyone thought I yeah join was a I
still hate him I respect this game I
don't like him and Charles Barkley was
on ESPN today and he said the thing that
made jordan so god better than all of us
was he took everything personal ya know
people don't take things personal he
never did it he never did another Sports
Illustrated interview after they they
put on the cover its Michael Jordan
embarrassing basket baseball he never he
never spoke or look at the kids halls
ever alignment his speech he'll chip
this big and just what even is the high
school backing code well yeah I should
have made the team like that remember
that yeah you but Charles Barkley when
they're in the finals
Charles scored 42 points is the the NBA
season MVP and join those June MVP is I
should he got that you're the MP watch
this and Charles goes it's the only time
I felt like I wasn't the best basketball
player on the court the only time my
career during those finals dudes a up
they have a story on their what in the
dream team it was Jordan his his LA
cañada players but not like the other
team those team had magic and bird and
David Robinson they were stacked and
join had the other team like the B team
and then went up nine points and Matt
John started talking [ __ ] to him and he
said II just wish I never did that cuz
then join went oh really and they start
and they said it was the best basketball
anybody's ever seen Mike Johnson at one
point threw the ball into the stands
they cuz he goes next I know Jordan
steams up by four oh my god and goes
we're talking the best of the best he
took over it was like I'm the alpha dog
he was after then he and they said big
on the bus and tension was so high and
then magic went well wish I didn't say
that everybody started laughing was like
that was the best game we've ever played
great the best of the bad
I mean yeah in Jordan it all extreme
winners Jordan took over and then how
about Jordan talks about when he's
playing against Clyde Drexler the Trail
Blazers was the team right you're
playing against in the finals and they
kept comparing slide Drexler to Jordan
and joined us it annoyed me that they
even compared him to me so what'd he do
so what'd he do he lit him up for 47
Jesus Christ what is that trouble it
annoyed me they compete he goes he's a
good player he's a great player but he's
not me and when they compare him to me
he does that to show them what is there
what is that a bed that me to be yes
that's just yes greatness this crazy you
forget how good is your call it's like
you are your own biggest fan like like
for real like you're just like the idea
that anybody would like he he we were
talking about how hard it is cuz you've
talked to champions and how hard it is
to especially fighters to stay at the
top heavy like everybody is yeah
everybody is you know gunning for your
position but for him it was the only
place you want to make sure you knew he
was the best yeah how funny is that he
said he goes my goal is 20 years from
now I want people to say Jordan would
still have dominate and of course he
would have what do you hear what they
did the number one pick Kwame Brown yeah
so Jordan was like this is the guy and
when he was playing for I think
Charlotte he was the GM and kwame's
number one pick and Kwame came to
practice cocky join comes out to on the
court in his business clothes there's a
given on one page Cain's again I picked
you he's right beats him one-on-one and
he's like I don't know 50 something
business I know what
beat his ass and they said one of the
reasons quantity on the bus is Jordan
broke them down I was like you're the
guy you're the number one pick this is
what you do just back them down
[ __ ] Gucci suit just such a month do
you you know watched on Olympics thing
because you have to think about it it's
David Robinson Shawn Kemp
Christian Laettner you know the best of
the best
no bet Magic Johnson Larry Bird the best
of the best and they give Jordan the B
team and he takes over do they say hit
the next nine shots in a row once they
start talking [ __ ] don't just to show
his alpha male yeah
damn that's so sick
then they go into his hole Jordan like
shoe stuff how he don't want he didn't
like Nike he wanted to sign with adidas
and they show him in a pair of DJ's I
thought I was gonna throw up they show
me an adidas and his mom's the one who's
like listen this is a new company yes
their track company but go out there
just see what they have to say they're
putting all this hard work and you owe
it to them to grab there see what they
say so they go out there and Jordan
still with AK I don't know man they give
him this pitch they signed him for the
first at the time they said it was
$250,000 the next athlete to get a shoe
endorsements making a hundred thousand
so cigar I'll take the money and his
agent goes well Nike you're in your
track shoes you're putting air in them
and you're calling them when their Nikes
well his gonna be here Jordan and that's
how that got started really Air Jordans
Wow it's fascinating and then the first
year they thought they they thought he
was gonna make well they said what we
want to do is make something like three
million over the three years in the
first year then I'm like twelve eight
million dollars I just blew it out of
the water
yeah he's just he's just even little
kids
he's just astonishing and I really like
Mike the commercial yeah he's just
astonishing he's a star real that'd be
like Mike commercial Gatorade yeah you
know the recreating that they're gonna
redo it with it haven't I think I I'm
pretty sure Zion Williams has in it
which is known I don't you know how I
didn't grow up with American sports yeah
and no but they were laughing so hard
cuz I was 23 and I was watching him play
basketball with my friends who were all
you know Irish tying he's critique in
New York no I went I said I went like
this I go I go I was like he's so good I
was just watching the aerial shots and I
was like he's so good he's like so
Jordan eight the next day that kept
going hey Who am I I got Michael Jordan
can play basketball he's really good you
know I mean I just for me I didn't even
know anything about basketball and I was
just astonished it wasn't it when they
show how good he was your thing like
content now it's a whole different thing
I got but the Charlemagne did tweet out
this he was saying how there it is Simon
Williams Jason Tatum all right all right
now the same that was but they did say
how impressive it is what
Brown has been doing since 18 you know
be in a social media world and all the
negativity and all the hate he gets yet
he still performs and dominates yeah go
Charlemagne's tweet uh chimp Charlemagne
straight on Michael yeah yeah you'll see
it the bronze looks oh no not twenty
years old since it was 19 mmm it's funny
see all the players don't know
everybody's neck is [ __ ]
I think his [ __ ] cuz they just lift
differently and probably doing something
oh there you go right would you say her
steroids in the NBA I don't know kill
that one can you imagine if MJ came up
in the social media or watching the
media pressure Jordan was under during
that first three-peat makes you respect
to LeBron even more for staying in his
is for staying sane his entire career
it's true LeBron's never broke he gets
so much hate mm-hmm I don't think Jordan
break though not with that mentality
because the only person close to his
meant I'd be Kobe and Kobe he scored 41
points with like a hundred and three
fever he had the flu
he had to flow a meter room into really
well Jalen Rose went on like I think I
don't know if he but the rumor is yeah
he was hungover but still hundred
whatever yeah yeah a flu or hungover
either way it didn't say so 43 points
saying you know whatever yeah
poisoned yeah his trainer said they had
a pizza my defeating this guy pizza
before a game you put in [ __ ] trash
in a Ferrari but so the game of this
pizza and strain was like dudes I
wouldn't eat this cuz he said like five
dudes dropped it off no one else ate it
and joint ate it and he's the only one I
got sick so it could be there you go
alright what do you say about it scroll
Rose allegedly found his way into
college party hung out with a bunch of
Indiana kids until they're eight hours
go down
hmm uno hungover or flu it's impressive
I'll say hungover is almost more
interested well I feel hungover right
now and asked me why I know is your
tummy hurt you drink wine unless no
pizza I ate some pie I had a lot of
pancakes this morning oh they said
adderall I guess no no I just I know I
mentioned I made my kids pancakes and
then there was leftover and I had a
shitload of it so you made a ton of
packets if you had a shitload of hiatal
I mean I'm Anton pancakes I just said
I'm gonna eat a stack of pancakes bad
right yeah well no no good tasty very
tasty
yeah little little dude I mean come on
what is wrong with a [ __ ] with
pancakes so you don't feel good he said
I just feel a little I feel like [ __ ] we
see you've hung over so that'd be my
head feels like it's in my head feels
like it's in pillows does that weird do
you think it's the pancakes I doubt it
my head feels like I'm like somebody has
pillows around my ears and my head's hot
my head's very hot
oh yes the pig I think the pancakes make
my doll it's not a fever everybody I'm
talking about I feel like I feel like
like whenever I do this I feel like my
eyes have pillows in them my head my
head I just feel like in wet cement when
I eat shitty food interesting yeah
I think it's an insulin rush you get
syrup with it
I sure did who the [ __ ] eats dry
pancakes - are you with butter sometimes
God deals butter yeah I [ __ ] love
panky so on American and I'll tell you
something else I like I like ice cream
sandwiches from cool house oh they're so
[ __ ] a I even like the [ __ ]
coconut ones that that cookie you put
them between two [ __ ] delicious
cookies hmm right there Tahitian that
Tahitian vanilla
aren't they German I don't know but that
dairy-free ones are really good too
they're all father's sugar in them hell
yeah can you see how much sugar is in
one of those goddamn sandwiches if
they're that tasty thank you dude
they're so good though I cut them up cuz
you don't want the big no I don't want
the whole one you want deeply then I'll
die 23 grounds 23 grams of sugar is that
a lot that's less sugar that's a lot but
not a lot
a cookie ice cream sandwich I would
imagine well not hold up hold up it's 60
grams well I'm sorry it's 43 grams oh
yeah see that's where I like it
46 grams of [ __ ] sugar and it's 530
calories and 330 are from fat mm-hmm
seems like 60 grams of carbs it seems
like quite a bit
thanks cream and you're counting
calories exploding ice cream [ __ ] off
right you need to get Kovac eat eat your
goddamn pancakes sometimes need an Ice
Cream Sandwich sometimes it seems like
you're doing every night bill Bubba no
no I've been good
my body hasn't my body's tired you're
lying I feel strong you're lying Brian
that beach cruiser and your deep
throwing ice cream saying I mean I'm
having some problems
yeah it's just this Cobra to do it today
I know I feel like I feel like we're
getting out of it they wanted to control
I feel like we're getting out of it Doug
oh the Governor of California just
announced that we're gonna be moving
into Phase two on Friday
phase two yes phase two so he's - I'm
exciting this Kyle eat your dick hold on
Phase two suck it let's break up don't
you bring it up like Jimbo you know but
I thought so everybody 15th May 15th is
one I think we you're gonna have to take
that out take that out not a lot to say
that enough beep all this out no no you
can't say that you know there's a
protest on this thing he's gotta hug do
you know there's a protest going on this
house yeah there should be he's been for
that's why people are saying is forced
to do this because of all the USA how
about when I got a ticket you're safe
around my bike did I show you the ticket
telling the story oh you know don't make
him look bad those are guys oh my god
the Rangers are great they come out by
just making foam to the rim mask in the
middle of nowhere
yeah and I go really fellas mass when
you go without oh come on take the mask
up they take the mask I did yeah and
they must have been like out [ __ ] yeah
they come what are we doing they know
who you were a big I did a bit though
big I did and I go uh what are we doing
I said you made me think out here yes
dude we don't want to do it either I go
I get it man don't worry about I'm gonna
talk my way out of it and part of me
want to give him a fake name and take
off but look the grown man of me was
like God just deal with it
yeah don't say my name is Chet Stevens
hey can I start rapping oh that's like
me that's the way I never expect to get
recognized ever and I'm I'm with my wife
at the time and I'm sitting there unless
I'm complaining about yeah I want to
hear it straight on go back it's to your
point as I'm sitting there complaining
I'm like what the [ __ ] but the food was
supposed to come and I'm being a
complete dick and she goes hey you're
being recognized by three people right
now that you can't do this so then I
have to be [ __ ] like all nice and
stuff let's get to it
okay sorry
so you're really nice cuz they recognize
you you dick yeah I just didn't want to
be a [ __ ] it's like when I complained
the [ __ ] manager cuz he charged me
for something I made a scene I walked
out and then a guy goes what do you
charge you for this fake bacon [ __ ]
[ __ ] this I go and I go yeah we'll take
it over that's too late I'm out I'm out
and then they I then they called me and
they said you know he's a fan he felt
really bad and of course I'm like I'll
give them free tickets I'm sorry I feel
terrible I call back I got you're a
hothead I have a [ __ ] text Roy your
fans should enjoy your fans you like I'm
never a dick it's just like sometimes I
get a little spazzy but go back to your
[ __ ] story I'm sorry uh nope story's
over now I get it
they did give me a ticket but Salo fine
it's like forty dollars yeah he goes and
I wait you know I've been out here every
day they go really I go how many days is
it there like like fifty some days ago
I've been on this bike path for 50 days
in our own egos Jesus I go I know how
much you take it he goes we're giving
you the lowest fine postures like 25 or
40 bucks on it sweet
see you tomorrow fellas they started
laughing of course see you tomorrow
see you tomorrow worth it when I'm sure
they knew it they like I'm sure I'm in
the middle of no and you say are you
guys gonna be around here where you
gonna be anything we don't know man yeah
they're like we don't know man only cuz
I other paths I can take they're like
just do your thing man and then he goes
ego and then I go what are we doing I go
dude look we're over a hat I go you're a
bikers yeah go welcome to the club so
fake boy bike club he's a big dude he
goes I know I know here's the thing dude
your biker how hard is it to go out here
just pretty tough on your win the middle
nowhere dude the only thing I've seen is
a bobcat don't think I'm gonna Cove it
from that yeah and he was I agree I go
so he goes but the problem is if a
thousand people think like you can get
out here that's prom I go Papa if a
thousand people come out here they're in
shape aren't they goes big time I go if
we all get covered we're gonna be fine
and I said also the Sun kills if we know
this he goes we don't know that I know
we do do you know we know that well so I
try to do the same thing you did try to
build a rapport the Ranger sitting there
or you know and I wanted to go up the
there's a Culver City place where there
stairs you go look out so I want to
drive them shut down so I pull cops
there and I go and he went mirror like
that cuz he thought I was gonna go so I
get out of my car and I go over and I go
hey Garcetti is a dick right what a
[ __ ] he is the [ __ ] is this he's a
[ __ ] and the guy goes dude he goes he's
not a [ __ ] we'd have a thousand people
crammed up there and it'd be a big
province wearing a mask there so ya go
really a guy go okay I'll see he goes
and he goes yeah alright he's over I was
embarrassed out that one makes a little
more sense if it's like you know I think
I don't think this shut down anything
I'll do nothing especially when it comes
to outdoor activities kami no Sun helps
everything and just for mental health I
think the Sun probably the best thing
you do but uh it is strange well well
with that bioluminescence now you know
that there's for the algae now when it
gets churned up will you go out to the
beach now at night and it's like that it
looks all it's it's crazy
it close so the beaches in Manhattan
Beach for [ __ ] Venice Beach and power
dude packed up and I said today and when
they try to clear out Venice people are
like nah they try to do it in Manhattan
Beach the same thing they're just like
you guys got to get out of here they're
like nah nobody cares
it's your beer costume on yeah I think
I'll be alright we're getting over the
hump I Friday I'm excited so Friday face
juice that means like yeah here so long
tattoo parlours yes here big boy bike
club have to come up oh I didn't boy
coaster club bookstores clothing stores
toy stores florists suck it florists are
dying you know all right there hadn't
hit
like hit really hard yeah you know why
yes you know I made stew by Phelps old
the floor you ever seen that young hot
florist I don't know I must say I don't
see their businesses oh they're going oh
boy ah boy yeah florist is dying that's
all right airlines are down 95 percent
son airlines should buy my takes now yes
I tried nits oh yeah I'm gonna go smoke
in yeah I gotta politics I got you
Spirit Airlines 74 dollars your honor
my first class Matt spear hey yeah blew
that once that was spirit
I hope we're gonna launch it I don't
think I bow your launches on chairs and
they go oh you want a luggage Papa well
you have to hold on to it and it's $100
oh my god look look look it doesn't
matter bike seat which goes right up my
[ __ ] is more comfortable own you want
refreshments we got tap water yeah tap
you'll take some tap water and a shove
Spirit Airlines dude get what you paid
for
so last time I ride fly spirit Arthur
guy goes okay he was being charged to
pass to his back it's not last time I
use spirits that's okay nothing makes me
more excited when celebrities especially
delayed of all time talk [ __ ] to that
Airlines United you should be ashamed of
yourself yeah it's like yeah sure yeah
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah you have to
use one of the major ones what are you
doing right now I got I've done that
before and they go we'll give you points
thank you for reaching out my mom they
don't give a [ __ ] dude now phase two
what's phase three
I think phase three would be places like
offices shopping malls and then gyms and
stuff
I think that's face - I think phase two
phase two malls aren't open we saw this
last time are you doing nicotine - chin
just a little bit Stage two I'm getting
new it you gonna kick patching you right
now oh you [ __ ] Haga team and guess
what do what Oh
that factors open and they just text me
sick boy bike club mergers new drop
Friday then boy Cruiser club will suck
you t-shirts
oh we're giving out tattoos stage
through will be high-risk business will
be able to reopen includes nail hair
salons gyms movie theaters I can't wait
to go to movie theater alright stage two
is we go to move stealing coffin your
face it Stage four will be the end of
the stay-at-home order Stage four I bet
we're at Stage four by omg non grocery
retail stores but with curbside pickup
[ __ ] off it's coming around dude oh dude
I'm so excited Thursday getting together
in my San Diego chapter boys this on
picture the bike I'll be running pretty
excited Santa Cruz I'm happy for you
thanks dude are we doing a bonus episode
on Friday my Friday yeah ok I'm just
driving up sending you and driving back
same day I like you get my mouths in and
come right back man I feel like you're
cruise no traffic what's not agree with
that's the best I love cruising mm-hmm
dude all I do you old [ __ ] a car
Metallica yeah I can't just [ __ ] hit
those trails dude just ride I ride a
little spill two spills took to spell
probably Papa's back it's all strawberry
I saw hurts I bet that showers not gotta
be a little careful huh that's part of
the gig dude that's why you know it's
like my friend Joey who was trying to
make trying to do it eventing what on
horses where the horses fall on you and
people die all the time
died when I was there no ride horses and
and the two Olympians came in when he
was in the hospital and they said you
have to stop and he goes whining this
cuz you're making mistakes we don't make
as you started too late I'm not saying
that's you I'm just saying yes horses he
was like yeah how'd your friend yeah
you're also told your forces my age now
quit ran horses though yeah you're
talking about the only thing gayer than
a banana seat right nope I'm not
inventing a grown man go ahead and pull
up
Sports Illustrated called a tan to that
and everything over the thigh jump over
car nothing gay they jump up a car
you should rat it often Hey Sports
Illustrated said it's the most dangerous
sport in the world it's this toughest
sport an older here hey they're nuts
oh yeah it's funky blurry dude and you
don't want to see the spills it's crazy
this is such an old video though rich
white people can [ __ ] up now then I
register they yeah you have to have a
sponsor but they're behind are like
here's a jump like watch cyst you watch
these jumps I couldn't believe how high
they were I was like what watch watch
it's much longer it's as long as the car
was jumping doesn't that's definitely
more dangerous than the guys that ride
the mountain bikes on the [ __ ] skinny
pass thousand five
well it's only dangerous if dude it's
not don't say that please don't say that
ask you ask you to not say no I'm saying
it is gay though there of mother the top
riders were are getting the men know the
whole things get some open all just
wearing out riders everyone has to be
small turn suits they're into tops and
their hat yeah look at the horses on the
horses all the horse does power but
you've got to be very stay over like
this Wow very still dude look oh my god
let's discuss how much money you're
right the horse is the athlete oh my god
dude I'm sweating it's all tears riding
that horse I'm sweating dude Heffley
doesn't tie takes a lot of control
Brennan oh my god using easier you're I
love when they say horse mcgrann uses
every muscle on your body
mmm shut the [ __ ] good and hang on yeah
we use you do use technically every
muscle because you're using your legs
and you're touching everyone i draining
and everyone tiny you can't be happy and
do that [ __ ] you'll be lightweight um
the women of the horseback riding world
are not always in the best of know they
look like warlocks
and they'll suck each other's [ __ ]
dude this is cat look it up sorry
can you say they said that's not true
that's not what I was saying you think
that's what they may not be as in shape
as CrossFitters let's just put all are
they out of shape why because the horse
doing all the jump in there are there
are there that you it's more it's more
out what's the word it's forgiving of
more of a you know that that would be an
excellent horseback ride she looks like
pickle rick who is pickle rick yes oh
dude new rick and morty dropped last
night [ __ ] that's snow [ __ ] no [ __ ]
rigs but i mean she kind of dial rate
kills rats dude that looks like pickle
don't she look like pathetic you're such
a bad guy man
yeah that's what's super day though I
never got and I don't mean like
homosexual you know what I mean
something yeah I do
oh she's hot yeah I don't think she's a
writer though they look like peewee
football players I want a ride I want a
ride sometimes I just want a few get off
our asses dude what's gonna break I want
to get on a bike I really do
I might start [ __ ] mountain biking
with you well if you're gonna smoke an
Saturday morning the clubs getting
together the spoke in Chapter maybe I'll
do that and I might be bringing up the
rear cuz I don't ride along that ain't
the time to start at one more advanced
you really come to more events for your
first try I don't know dude okay maybe
I'll make a quick appearance and say
what's up you guys up mall jerseys hold
on fresh out ok hold on maybe I'll hold
the flag and go like this
ready set go we're gonna do what you
know hold the water for me come by and
we grab it
ah oh you said a water it'll be vodka
suckers nope [ __ ] you
hey be this Saturday UFC 249 is going
down dude and you can make a little
money do draftkings the leader in one
day fantasy sports putting you in the
center of the action well I mean you I
mean you you're taxing so you're not
listening I'm gonna same dude get into
the action with a shot to share 1
million dollars with your first upon
million dollars 1 million million
million and I can bet on MMA yeah you'll
see do 49 can bet on dude I know
fighters I can just I can pick just 6
spiders
stand to the salary cap and pile up
points for advances takedowns and more
yeah there's no better way to put your
MMA knowledge to the test and compete
for sure at 1 million million million
dollars add red olives dollars dollar
nothing makes the UFC event more
exciting then when you have skin in the
game with draftkings download the draft
app draftkings download the draftkings
app now and use the promo code fighter
to get free shot at a share of 1 million
dollars in prizes with your first
deposit that's promo code fighter to get
free shot at share a share dude a share
of a million prize with your first
deposit only at draft Kingdom $5 deposit
eligibility restrictions apply see draft
kings.com for details oh good news
everybody this week on it has 25% off
all their supplements from alpha brain
alpha brain instant you had a new mood
melatonin spray you got problems with
you got they got total gut health
protein powder
dude the protein powder creatine
25% off and I know a lot of you boys
behind that quarantine 15 shred that
wait man let on it help 25% off this
week only go to on it comm slash fighter
an additional 10% off and then they're
given twenty five percent off
supplements say what 35 what why net.com
slash fighter some pretty Krunk for
phase two though dude can I ask you a
question what shoes do you wear when you
ride you have your bike shoes I wear
ride concept MTB book and a nice thick
board gonna be putting out some shoes
it's the guys doing that baby did I have
a conversation with specialized yes I
did there you go why would you I don't
like I don't like clip-ins though I
don't like clippings for mountain bikes
yeah I guess are you looking for it are
you'll be able to boards just say what
happens when you fall when you have
clippings well you can you can clip out
but you'll be pretty [ __ ] on it I
guess some guys use clippings I don't I
like to be able to [ __ ] jump on
nervous on a road bike uni clip-ins you
get more power than coz up you can pull
up you know Jesus look at that that's a
clip ins how long you been
how far did you go you went 21 miles
resign I went 20 sup 25 miles or
something on the ebike and then I went
15 miles on my standard long way for 15
months
two hours cuz you're just up and
downhill is up with the up how much how
much pedaling are you doing a ton you're
in shape getting there I your body's
changed a little bit I will be honest
what's that by two it's the what to get
to the top is what's cutting the
calories I'm so exhausted by the time I
even start the ride just to get up to
the top so tired that's that bad member
there oh we could specialize going down
the big boy moose thanks for educating
Kalyn how the fish boys roll dude that
specialized the company a specialized
I'd like a bike hmm and I want my son to
have one he's eight I want to take him
bike riding a real problem what I want
to bite my soul what's a bike that's not
what the club is dude but I want I want
a thought is this a charity no but I
want to represent you'll have money no I
have to I bought mine not by my eyes you
owe me a bike okay but I'm just saying I
don't know what kind of bike to get so
maybe specialize could help me and if
they have one Papa can help you but
specialize probably knows what's good
for my body I'm 511 170 all muscle you
know you're just not you know I hate to
be shitty gonna hurt sales come on man
that's a [ __ ] unfair I don't want to
say why your membership is revoked
that's not why man in great shape you
know this you know I'm in great shape
you saw me leaping dude the the Ferrari
or the Porsche gt2 of all bikes yeah
it's a specialized levo turbo SL that
they there's no they had on their side I
don't need that I just need a starter
bike get me a starter bike then I think
you should get huffy I'm not getting a
[ __ ] huffy now I want to worry about
what is specialized they're a good
company no I'm [ __ ] I want to
represent specialized no yeah nope
what about the beginners club yet to go
get on the [ __ ] horses you're talking
abut Skol it old starters mature
starters 6,000 the turbo
expansive levo it's like 13 grand I
think Jesus Christ isn't the one that we
were looking at last time with a gold
chain
that's an expensive begin one are you
gonna be another guy who's gonna have 15
bikes now oh yeah gotta do it right
got the stable bro oh you like horses
check out my face what I do
check out my statement come by and I
take one of your bikes you're stealing
I'll do it in a heartbeat no with the
promise what you just smile hold on
you're too small
oh but I can lower the seat no but the
shocks are set for guys 260 pounds the
whole thing set up for my side really
you can't when it was jumping on the
trampoline yesterday right and that
trampoline wasn't me I was an Olympic
trampoline boy oh boy that was a crater
the thing was smooth yeah it's good that
that trampoline but it kind of rounds
you bring a little if you keep doing I
don't mind it that's good good for you
pick a rig I didn't see the new Rick and
Morty anyone watch me good morning to
old super old cat and might I trot tried
to get around to watch me and I get
distracted with other things like right
now I'm watching the last Kingdom on
Netflix is it good it's pretty good
people keep telling me that Vikings is
better and that I should watch that out
I've heard Vikings Oh Chris de Stefano
said Vikings I'm watching Ozark oh yeah
that's another one Ozark well everybody
finished that oh I don't know quarantine
phase one I've been here I just didn't
even caught up on the last dance I'm
back on it that's true Mozart's one the
good adult I'd say it's pretty good I
wouldn't say it's as good as like Game
of Thrones or anything but I'm sick of
I'll be watching old [ __ ] I just really
think he's fine that's really what it is
not a look at him he's just so pretty
busy yeah it was beautiful eyes yeah
full mouth round face I finished colors
on Amazon what your ending is have you
seen it no good the ending is just
shocking yes so you recommend I love the
Nazi stuff yeah very good show
very good Oh 9 out of 10 9 out of 10 oh
dude if you're not it's first of all to
my one of my favorite errors it's in the
70s it's 1977 New York
chaos yeah New York their Nazi hunters
Jordan peels a producer of it so he's
brilliant Al Pacino's the head Nazi
hunter the kid from that kids in fury
everybody's young kid who can't kill and
fury he's phenomenal in it it's just
really good man some great TV out there
man I've never having an Amazon ISM yeah
it shows we bagged you see free back I
have it oh please watch it I loved it I
was just like you know what you know it
gets rave reviews is the tick now if you
remember I was a kid
tick was a cartoon of a blue guy typing
the tick I'm actually wanted me to
audition for this
I didn't cuz I put the suit and flat not
for me but apparently it's supposed to
be a great show it looks absolutely
ridiculous yeah well I love that actor
that's good he so you're gonna audition
for this they want ya they sent out a
casting call for me when passed on it so
in that situation Bubba
they knew they who they wanted which was
half the battle the reason that they
have auditions for that is publicity
will come in she had the word out yeah
it's very real what I wouldn't hide
why'd I turn down I just what I just
knew that that he was the ticket yeah
yeah the cartoon was big I had the video
game on Sega Genesis as well it's funny
I think it's really funny apparently
they take yeah it gets crazy reviews
does it [ __ ] I watch it when I watch
that Nazi stuff the Holocaust holy [ __ ]
dude
yeah the horrible [ __ ] that they did
it's uh it's astonishing
oh dude you know trying to keep me up at
night you know ruin you oh yeah I watch
a documentary it shows these these moms
holding their kids going to the gas
chamber it's like well I I like how the
[ __ ] my area was Nazi Germany in college
I was a history major nothing and and
and yeah and and what happened but but
but what happens is when you when you
see that and you saw that rabbit hole
it's astonishing
and also you then can't really
about your life what what happened you
don't look at people you know I take
politics a little bit seriously or these
I read philosophy I read these things it
primarily it's because I'm trying to
negotiate that this problem of evil and
how it can happen and seems to happen
although I'm reading ghost scores which
I think you'd really like it's a book
about the secret CIA war the secret CIA
wars of Afghanistan the Thurman's and
yeah and it really fascinated Middle
East really really good the West even
Cole and I I was recommended by see how
you got to me
and again talked about an unlucky part
of the world and lucky he's read it but
but it was recommended by a guy who's
currently in the CIA and I'll tell you
something man it's it's again it's like
he want to Pulitzer Prize for this but
again you [ __ ] you [ __ ] read these
books and you realize how lucky we are
to be living now in the United States
because there are times when you had no
recourse and you would just be killed
you would watch your children be it's
incidents it's also Harper I'm glad
you're watching and I'm so heartbreak
I'm glad you're kind of feeling it
because I booked I just got the book the
third right oh wow actually about that
book good for you just very impressive
giant Nazi logo on it though that's okay
I know I know but I heard someone have
the covered on that was that was
Hitler's the Third Reich was supposed to
be the right there but lasted thousands
and so the the hunters show is Bob see
it's it lives in some truth because
there was Nazis that came over the
United States tons of them actually NASA
stuff like that yeah but these Nazi
hunters they're hunting these Nazis
who's trying to start the fourth right
yes
it's fascinating yes I've got some other
books for you after when you're done
with that until listen up there right
there oh yeah it's thick but I'm glad
you're reading it man but I get all my
reading done when I'm on tour I read in
the hotel I read on my flight my pastime
right but I'm not int why I don't read a
ton I just read magazine sir I would
recommend to anybody listening sometimes
historical books can be a little dense
right and they get you get busy or so
one of the things that I would recommend
is historical novels that have been
researched so Exodus by Leon URIs the
founding of the State of Israel Oh
Jerusalem is amazing freedom at midnight
they're certain certain books that are
that are but here clean is that that
third reich book is 1200
as long reads a hundred pages a day
you're knocking that out pretty fast
yeah yeah that's a lot of pages but yeah
I mean I'll do it on the fly I'll knock
some [ __ ] oh that's great yeah I mean
I'll be very impressed if you read that
book I read that that's a great book I
mean and and and it's not easy but good
for you yeah very good to learn about
that and very good to feel uncomfortable
very good to lose some sleep sometimes
about the horrors that have happened in
history because in a way it's respect
for the dead it's respect for the
sufferer the ones who suffered it's and
it's also keeps you aware of when hiring
a government yeah when a government can
get and why this experiment called the
United States and and I see why people
get off see this is I'm not comparing
anything to Nazi Germany and Hitler and
stuff like that but like when I posted
that those people gave me a ticket in
the parks dude when I say people are
upset I mean up not the not the Younger
down the older demo up right they're
taking away now right well I'm like whoa
dude well I'll be fine I'll be back
tomorrow like you don't understand it
starts with how much how much freedom
money let me take away from you so when
I posted about Eric Garcetti and I was
criticizing him and being dramatic
little dramatic yeah being dramatic I
called him a tyrant that vote was being
dramatic with strong language I I didn't
I don't read my comments but Will Sasso
called me and said you got a lot of
really negative stuff and I'm a little
worried that people are gonna take it
out of context what he was just worried
about me but but the point is it was it
was young people who don't who don't
understand or that haven't had to have
the background knowledge so very I'm
very sensitive to it
so but of people who are educated like
yourself and I'm not but but I'm
learning I'm getting there but even Tim
Kennedy like he was like they gave you a
[ __ ] ticket yeah yeah dude yeah like
this ridiculous blah blah blah but they
cuz they know yeah you know what y'all
see this is what Americans are vigilant
Americans should be always very
suspicious of the government we've
always been they gave me my ticket
and I [ __ ] fell on my bike and I got
strawberry all over my back and I'm
listening to Rage Against the Machine oh
dude you're
your marijuana start a [ __ ] revolt
yeah Marik I want to [ __ ] but that's
what happens and you know what I really
like about how people go down that rap
well what I like what about what you're
saying is that you watched hunters and
what happened was because you it
elicited horror and also compassion in
your heart like you went
this is terrible you're seeing a mother
walk to it with a baby clutched to her
right that is a feeling of compassion
and horror right you you and now you
want to learn more about this evil but
you know where it's hard before that
when I did a show for history never
enter no big deal shot four episodes no
big deal but they're making World War
two model remember this and they're
making World War two models and I was
the host and they said do you have any
connection World War two I went oh my
grandpa was in here set shot by Nazi and
tried to call my dad and get some
information and give him the this up you
know some facts about my grandpa and
when I found out all the stuff about my
grandpa's like holy and I went down this
weird rabbit hole of World War two it's
not smashed remember when you called me
a bell but but you know what else is
yeah but you know what else is weird is
talk about you know being lazy stuff
like that you know this is well
documented
you know when d-day how we surprised him
to storm the beach of normally stuff
like that you know that someone went to
Hitler to tell them what we were doing
but he slept in they weren't ready for
it Wow but they went that they knew they
got word that we were storming the
ditches and they went to go tell him and
he didn't he didn't he was lackadaisical
about it because he's being lazy that
day no insane is that yeah but for
history's first orys what else they and
also Nazi his original not Hitler his
original plan wasn't to kill all the
Jews his original plan was to just get
him out of jail
well they were gonna push him beyond the
euro yeah exactly they were gonna do
against where they were gonna kill him
like they were there in your rhythm that
he wouldn't talk to some other was it
Mussolini and my way off on this well
mostly it was was a contemporary and was
the Nick tater of Italy yeah and he
wouldn't he wouldn't go talk to him and
he goes kill and they say and that's
where it started yeah I don't the final
it's called the final solution right so
they're they're books written on this
the final solution was when Hitler got
his inner circle together and said the
final solution this is what we're going
to do we are going to we are going to
kill all the Jews so in it his original
plan was just a push yes there there
oh they do they're like know what to do
about it but primarily what happened was
as they went through the Russian Ukraine
okay as the Nazis went through Russia
they wanted to create an area an open
area free of Russians for the new race
for German the one the absolute Germans
do
so if you see what the Nazis did in the
Ukraine and in Russia it is so horrific
the SS the the elite troops that were
indoctrinated in Nazi ideology and the
soldiers a lot of these kids were like
18 19 year old kids they were rounding
up entire villages making men take their
own graves and they would shoot them
into these holes and then the Russian of
German boys they didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were like they were watching
women hold it and they were shaking and
and there's this famous thing where
Heinrich Himmler who was the head of the
SS got up and made a speech to them in
the field explaining why this was
important for Germany and it was dirty
work but they would be heroes but the
horror of what they did so the the whole
scale murder of entire villages almost
Oz who's an Israeli writer said his
mother killed himself herself and he
said I forgive her he said what do you
mean he said in one day in her town in
the Ukraine the Nazis in one day killed
25,000 people everyone she knew everyone
that knew her friends everyone and so
they shot 25,000 people in one day and
he said so everything she knew her
history we've all gone it's unfastening
Cubao t' all the Jews were killed in
that area it was this beyond and and the
regular villagers I mean they they date
and they raped and they did all kinds
what else is interesting to is uh you
know with the tanks and they were trying
to figure out the Americans trying to
figure out how Nazis were getting
through these mountains in snowy areas
so much but Nazi Iran and feta means
there aren't tons of mass tons of math
yeah and they were walking yeah and
Americans like how the [ __ ] are they
getting it they're not sleeping yeah but
the thing is is this and they didn't
know it's the time they're taking all
this all these and feta means and math
and all the stuff but it catches up with
you so then they got really tired and
that's
we come and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I tell
you what else what happened in the Nazi
a you know yeah [ __ ] no you hold on but
the Nazis as they as as they when the
war was over and the Russians started
coming into Germany there was some real
score settling because you know more
Russians died than any other anybody
else exactly right more Russian side no
more Russian side maybe for 20 million
anyone 20 million maybe 30 million
Russell talked about that uh-huh no we
tense after that killed another 49 in
that crazy more Russians on World War
two than any other country yeah
Russia softly other group is Russia
Russia a flat Russia's a flat area and
it was just you know and what else is
interesting is I know people are like
dude there's a whole program for when we
took over you know beat the nut stuff
like that we took their smartest minds
in science estates the scientists
because in it's it's it's a double-edged
sword because if we didn't do that they
would want to rush that's right so
that's why and they would they were
working out on a rocket they were
working on nuclear with us they were
working on rocket and because of those
unfortunate because they are Nazis
because those Nazis came to America
they're the main reason we got the
little I'm so glad I'm so glad you're
reading about this it's so awesome to
see you reading about this because I'm
just laughing like that and it may have
happened eighty years ago but it's still
very relevant for a low my job it forms
the reason our world it was the the
destruction of Old Europe and and the
creation of the new world a new woody
new order you know didn't say yeah
that's he's so hard piss piss hard you
[ __ ] my second lease a neo-nazi dick
dude no youth Matthew remember you would
have been rounded up as a big you would
have been forced to log dude because
there's no worry it'll Hitler with hello
no guys I'm I've been [ __ ] dude
Hitler had me put out you a little too
dark a little to you look a little Greek
or something you know well do you think
it would kill me I'll tell you who they
would have took only used to flock they
would took clock Wow I'm just clock
would have been clock but I've been a
stable horse yes you've been mr. hands
100 percent just banging banging away
yeah maybe though you got good miss I'm
a huge anti-nazi dick a piss now usually
they make you drop
pants if you're circumcised or a Jew if
you weren't yes circumcision is what I
do you know you would you know drop your
pants let's see your dick if you were
circumcised get on the train I don't
have a sock on mine I'm not Jewish but I
am circumcised everybody can you
probably not know a sock get a sock
that's off but it's not a sock like
let's move too much information but my
girlfriend didn't mean no I was
circumcised she thought I wasn't you
know wasn't Wow well she thought I was
okay well that's about all right it's
congratulations sleek sleek sleek and
sweet that's good you were born in Korea
yeah my thighs are super against it were
you born in Seoul Seoul yeah well a lot
of parents now are against it
circumcision it's a religious thing that
Americans took because was you know
apparently more sanitary or less prone
to infection venereal disease they don't
know if that's true anymore if you have
if you have it you know why it's super
like it's silly yeah yeah it's like it's
like washing your hands yeah I don't
have to wash mine I just at the
waterfall do I wash your brush back up
peeling it back so they always watch
your whistle I clean my whistle my you
know that whenever you see me walking
around I have a clean whistle dirty
hands clean with I know hands dirty
hands clean whistle that's right and our
sinks over here I'm dirty I'm very clean
about certain things like that
I don't like poo you know I don't like
sitting on public toilets I don't think
there is anyone who likes it yeah I
don't think there probably are some
freaks do you use the paper thing I
always use a paper hover you hover okay
that's better yeah girls would do that
too they'll put the paper thing down and
then we'll squat and hold it so we're
like hovering right above I wish I could
be able to squat like that there's no
way I could do that you can't hold it I
can't hold that I'm too big too I'm
feeling just too big no you just don't
work on your got to and you not do this
I could do that but I can't squat on a
toilet no I feel like I want to fall on
my
my foots gonna slip out or some text
because you're stupid governor finally
opened up you can't stick every time you
use like say a text from Jay I always
hear in his voice so funny it's so funny
the governor opened up my god I want him
to be my road manager Jay nope Jay is
the head of fig boy merch and all things
stick boy by clubs dammit
we're organizing a hole are we in take
over Catalina Island maybe what does
that mean
big boy festival doing thick boy fast
yeehaw dude it's endless and the MER
stops friday papa all right man I don't
know dude you know mm-hmm well I think
we covered all of World War two Nazis
good stuff this was an educated monday
let's see what we got for current events
nazi Monday Nazi Monday first one hey so
a couple of youtubers have posted up
several videos I think it's a three-part
series on to their channel where they're
trying to see if they can trick
celebrities into thinking that they're
doing interviews with other celebrity TV
hosts by using old footage and doing
zoom meetings and so they did it with a
couple people but they actually tried to
see if they would get Carroll Baskin to
do it and make her think that she was
doing an interview with Jimmy Fallon
while showing that stupid [ __ ] hat
she thought that's that's just her
that's her thing she's a flower child
Regina
yeah they ended up getting an interview
with her and they took old clips from
Jimmy Fallon using the word cat over and
over
and she thought that the interview was
kind of weird but she wasn't bold enough
to come out say is this this is fake
while she's getting interviewed I mean
what does anybody ever get yeah not
after Kovac 19 what's Jimmy phone's
voice we're ever going to be able to do
tours again okay that's amazing Wow
what's living gonna be Jimmy Kimmel I I
got a [ __ ] dude when I was doing
MADtv and I was a new actor and I did
this thing and the guy was like so Brian
: I was like it's Callen and they're
like cat :
so tell us about what's it like to work
with Roseanne okay I go I'm working on
MADtv and I could not be [ __ ] with
Brian : hey man it's Catholic I'm bad
and then I was like this son of a [ __ ]
got me so well there are a couple of
celebrities who just let people call
them by the wrong name I used to come in
to when I was doing press Evert when I
was on the road ice coming pretty like
elbow take carry and stuff like that but
now you'll be you'll be ready to go yeah
we're with you got a roast them or
whatever you'll be ready to go oh yeah
because some would come in and be like
oh let's [ __ ] with them you know you
come and come Adam some Adam you come
out of yeah yeah yeah especially if it's
a bunch of dudes some nice you're gonna
do the older dudes they're over it they
already don't like you see you gotta you
know and what's going on fellas you know
yeah stick it yeah stick it to him don't
don't [ __ ] letter just light up like
the sidekick we just light him up then
they're like oh [ __ ] right then they
back up that's when they back off oh
yeah so this is a quick one Joe exotic
is actually working on a street wear
clothing line with let's see Oh ginger
yeah um he's been speaking to somebody
who owns a clothing line they wanted to
do like a club and from jail he is
signing off on his likeness as well as
designs that he's willing to release
smart he is very excited to get out of
jail because he is super yeah he's so
excited about being a star sure when is
he gonna get out of jail the first of
never I mean he's there for a while or
how long
so for 20 years he did get 22 years I
think he's only done a couple though
couple years I think he's gonna done
like four years right three years yeah
it's not very long he's got someone yeah
the dragon apart from Trump you think
that she watched the Trump on the
townhall because they can't do it at
townhall so they doubt the Lincoln
Memorial know last night on Fox
it was interesting right mm-hmm you
think to have a vaccine by the end of
the year experts say where it takes 15
months but Trump's attending yeah and
then she asked one question about China
I like what he's doing with China but
they asked one Chris Pratt China goes
I'm not giving up my cards here that's
ridiculous question I'm gonna I'm in a
chess game I can't give away my hand and
what you're asking me how you give away
my hand chocolate yeah exactly this is
interesting
good I think that China China had the
worst year of the the unless it's the
worst year economically because of the
the stuff Trump's been doing in the last
70 years listen man I I think that they
should be held responsible for a lot of
this [ __ ] I I'm I'm saying I know I can
real with what he was I agree I agree
this [ __ ] China policy mister and he
was saying this way before anyway before
I was like I was critical of him I was
like whatever and it's [ __ ] you
know I was like god he looks like [ __ ]
though would it kill you it'll work out
dude no he doesn't work out you think
you only have so many beats yeah yeah he
simply she have a battery and don't use
the money he said that to the sky ran
triathlons he was like this guy's all
tidings what are you doing he goes I was
gonna train my triathlon he goes you're
gonna die young I wonder I wonder if
exercise no it's fun exercise it helps
me yeah a lot of exercise might wear you
down but I don't think so yeah yeah
I usually 20th on says he really thanked
when he was 10 to 20 years I thought
before that ma'am oh he's gonna be there
for a while
but was he serving time before he was
sentenced I'm sure but even that not
no no he'll be sorry I thought I thought
if you did a crime he couldn't make any
financial gain I like like serial
killers get selling me merch or as he
can you can't make money off the crime
but you can make money
well like off of your likeness yeah I
think it always will cuz I think George
Zimmerman tried to do something similar
after his whole thing that guy's such a
piece of [ __ ] yeah well he showed up at
rallies made like meet-and-greet
appearances what else you got - yeah
okay so another IG live video gone wrong
so dj khaled went on IG live and they
have a feature now where you can add
people in and a lot of celebrities have
been adding in fans just to have
conversations with people that have
supported them and just play the video
oh god that's so funny who is that girl
by the way we look her up just a fan
she's fantastic
she's Jesus what a freak I'm love for
everybody please take it easy yes I have
a family a family god damn dude okay so
another one do you remember when dj
khaled was doing the Stairmaster all the
time oh yeah and I would always give
like
advice like bless of your major key yeah
I was like his big just stopped
he's again in shape for a little bit he
just stopped all right think we out here
getting healthy y'all and then just kind
of but he never really changed you look
any more good have a shirt off yeah
what's this
okay so uh Machine Gun Kelly recently
made a video that he posted onto
Instagram where he found out that his
next door neighbor who is nice his name
is Jeff Lewis everything that's his name
his neighbor his bay is a host of a show
and he also has a podcast and he MGK
found out about this podcast listen to
it and realized that his neighbors hate
him and he just made this video um
Colson across the street oh oh yes now I
have no issue with this guy there's this
whatever tension brewing and he said it
was actually gonna turn into the movie
neighbors and that he is Zac Efron which
means that I'm [ __ ] Seth Rogen
yesterday the way Machine Gun Kelly's a
dirty 30 birthday a lot about him that's
I can bet to them five thirty is day
drinking a big cake in the shape of it
the tower right you can see your house
in the background they slip parking from
the fire hydrant they parking from the
fire iron about we're talking about the
people's driveways it's just like I
think they're so [ __ ] up yeah they
just just stopped the car wherever it
right where an explorer dies just in
front of the G with the G Wagen that was
blocking my neighbor's boy boy they have
to understand I don't hate them
right my neighbor's hate them yeah cuz
my neighbors have complained about them
to me every time the cops show up or
every time a car gets towed or every
time somebody gets a ticket they're
assuming it's me it's not now I know
okay
Jeff as the new guy on the block
referring to you I wish we would have
had a chance to meet I'm sure there's
years of noise to come from my house so
I hope that we just have mutual
understanding and if you ever need
anything just come knockin until then
I'm gonna send this over your way cheers
neighbor all right
Coulson across the street is he big
machine comes no no I'm saying does he
make a lot of money yeah he's very
popular and his neighbor got it well
that's cool so I'll be friends that's
cool okay no move your car
I said no please move your car that's
hilarious that's nice all right all
right this is more serious one but that
mass shooting in Canada that kind of
just like what swept under the rug has
all this pandemic stuff troduce Trudeau
announced a ban on 1500 types of assault
firearms like right away around if that
happened we like Trudeau I don't really
I mean I think he's super liberal and
just come here see when he's making fun
of Trump no he's um I'm sure I'd like
him I'm sure he's fine I don't know I I
had the answer is I don't know I don't I
mean as of today the mark for assault
weapon he's so [ __ ] politically
correct it's like well mankind he goes
person kind everything all right dude
you know he's just he's just a little
he's a little too woke a politician do
we like though I mean but he's just who
do we like them you know give me one you
like no I mean I think the whole
politician I think all of us would be I
think all of us would behave very
differently if we were in a position of
power like that because we'd have to
like there's certain things you do that
wouldn't be very popular mm-hmm speaking
of politicians if Donald Trump won and
this guy is I think he's a comedian and
he did this with the recording of Donald
Trump
[Music]
[Laughter]
so is here so you're like this guy's a
real hash-table it's all ears
alright and that is Carlos Moline
underscore and this isn't a post with
Kenai bro
Keenen Ivory Wayans he's gotten older
yeah he looks a lot older than me okay
hi everybody this is Keenen Ivory Wayans
I just want to say congratulations to
the class of 2020 I know this sucks you
worked your ass off and now you don't
even get to walk but that's what makes
you the greatest generation of this new
millennium in the face of a global
pandemic you stayed focused continue to
work hard and achieve your goals that's
the kind of leaders we're going to need
in the future I wish you guys all the
best keep striving
keep smiling yes yes yes and yes that's
a joke but it's what I was [ __ ] the
reigning that's great
all right it's great I've auditioned for
him a couple of times smart
[ __ ] all the Wayne brothers say
he's like oh he's the corsa brain Living
Colour Emily he's so special I think
that he invented the whole machine
behind it and this is stuff that Brian
was talking about the bioluminescence
that's the dolphin swimming in the
bioluminescence Oh
some neon dolphin yeah as you disturb
the algae mm-hmm they they go bad they
freak out me they let off you know
electric charge essentially what's
amazing right yeah so in during the day
it looks red in the out that's the
coolness yeah you can go right now to
the beach and watch at night the waves
look like that yeah they're beautiful
all right um here's a quick one the
mountain the mountain he broke the
record for deadlift but like by a
massive amount and there was like
nothing to
pounds how much does he weigh though
chin look after this but he's in
enormous force pretty sure his
proportions are crazy too
I hope he's so happy he's so big
you've seen one gimmick time let a
little kid
500 one kilograms one thousand one one
one hundred and four pounds a British
man held directed before this and now
that he wants to box him there's some
people yell on the background it's
pretty I feel like he gave you two one
more bring up how much he weighs though
chin huh
so he rolled eleven hundred pounds and
he weighs he's so big there's a cool yet
you know he had a stroke and that's why
his face like yeah yeah Bell's palsy or
something like four he weighs 400 it's
incredible 85 Eddie hall was the one who
had the record before he's short and
stocky huh
he weighs 425 pounds named kid playing
basketball skinny not skinny of it
skinny how much do the most you've ever
deadlift do you know close six under
close to 600 a lot of weight I don't
know Bob I feel like you do more because
you were doing 550 for 10 reps yeah I
don't know I mean but that's not true
that you do cuz Jay told me you were
doing 700 pounds maybe all I know this
guy do you know remember that makes me
yeah but sell us a lot of weight you
said that the bar was bending yeah well
but I mean why did you say 600 I ride
bikes I know but you were do word you
were [ __ ] doing 550 time I know but
real quick he weighs 425 pounds that's
1100 your times body weight 2 times the
body weight plus impressive it's not 3
times close to 3 yeah it is actually
so that'd be like you doing how much tap
I think you're pretty close no hmm if I
train more often I I was told I can
probably do 3
fifteen she's my tried to compete but I
don't know I don't like the idea of
competing in powerlifting anymore I
don't like the idea of you competing
powerless it's fun but yeah Eddie Hall
did have the record
so he's 425 pounds though you know he's
six nine six foot nice 31 its young to
house truck he's 31
I had no idea I mean you're doing a lot
of different stuff nick name name name
asteriod I mean name a Swedish steroid
he's brown yeah he's I see all right
hey let me see him when he was younger
top four
Jude impressive just 425 pounds though
you know yeah here's the timeline that
was him doing six yeah that means that's
a whole ton of supplements because he
what he filled out he probably would
have filled out you know bones that's
how you look before there's no way
without a bunch of what steroids can do
he's so big co-star this is girlfriend
no no co-star
Game of Thrones but this guy's even
bigger that guy he's the guy with the
skinny legs [ __ ] is that guy
it's a lot of William does all of your
Richter's from that look he's he's
currently the tallest buddy bill on
earth powerful big yeah he's huge
alright next one is a man was caught
camping in Disneyland or Disney World's
Discovery Island he thought it was
paradise no look at his picture for god
sakes yeah there's other pic probably
you know hey have you ever heard the
Walt Disney Nazi ties I have it's on
record he attended a lot of Nazi party's
probably a meetings by rail racist yeah
all right you guys have seen this by now
all right
oh yeah something called the murder
Hornet I have that's the one that coyote
Pearson said was the most painful yeah
it's that the giant Asian Hornet it made
its way to the US Hammond
sounds like something going around now
Washington what 6/3 Washington a
fantastic question time kill 35,000 bees
in 93 hours oh I've seen where this
[ __ ] up all those bees yeah yeah and
they also have that like you don't get
only go after human beings but if you
mess with their home which happens to be
on the ground so if you step on the
d'être yeah it's on the ground it's on
the ground the other thing I was on the
ground oh and my guess regular bee suits
don't work and they're called murderer
horny yeah yep they decapitate fabulous
this is a hard to kill steps on its nest
which it makes it rather lonely in the
grip on the ground you have enduring any
unlucky SAP on the receiving end of a
murder or an attack is what you're like
killed about 50 people in six flying a
year you up to 25 miles per hour and the
potential for multiple stamps in the
same Hornet these things can be
excruciating ah one-off sing and amaz
holy [ __ ] those that survived they last
for a month keeps going down soon huh
it's hard to kilcher and they've made it
to the US but just Washington yeah but
that means they're headed this way
yeah I would just get drought drones
drone robots go in there fall come up to
work drone bees here's a scary clip I
saw this from boss logics Instagram page
it's supposed to be somewhere in
Indonesia I saw this monkey trying to
get the kid but the monkey came up on a
little motorcycle and then try to grab
the kid it's just freaky hold on see
little motorcycle then grabs this kid
look what's stronger thing is oh my god
I like how that guy just came after
yelling at her mom backed off that was
not a mono foot on a mini motorcycle is
going on here is that thing trained drag
attacks that's the thing that people
that's impossible yeah kid it's possible
it's trained to steal kids who knows
I'll go ahead and kill that monkey go
fine no follow monkey back to its
trainer yeah yeah but also kill him like
an N and then we kill the trainer and
the monkey double I'll make the trainer
eat the monkey you know take your bat to
the monkey ate monkey brains for lunch
then found the trail everybody dies
everybody dies everybody you all die
everybody all of you does yeah and if
you're there with friends they're gonna
die - yeah and this is just the last
once a happy one that's someone sent in
hilarious you saw this - this - I guess
this dad's been training a son for for a
baseball for a long time you can see his
progression throughout and then this is
him hitting this thing over the fence ha
ha
how old is it music it's a little little
tiny kid but the dad's reaction yeah
and did that threw the pitch pretty fast
- that's so [ __ ] cool you make sure
that's my son let me see how-- gonna
have teams for that Adam they threw it
fast
hot chicks suck yeah how old is that kid
that's fast all right it just move okay
yeah that went far - and then that's
Cory get motivation baseball that's his
actual Instagram that's cool woman yeah
that's really good man yeah there's a
little baby that super cute yeah that's
him younger - thank you that kid in the
lead yep and that's pretty much it well
he was all right yeah well kids were you
doing there I saved your video and
nursing your back that's alright just
get power through it do its called a
strawberry I'm ask you this what we call
in the streets of strawberry when you
bike 21 miles do you come back and do a
little exercise no that's your day that
spent are you doing a lifting are you
taking time help just by you trimming up
biking trim it up biking trimming up
I'll you can trim it up
I bike take boy pick boy trim yeah lead
by example we win right now don't we
myself okay you know I can makes a
little depressed no I just don't have a
scale who gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah alright
alright dude well grats buddy thanks pal
good boy merch drops Friday pop out man
then boy March 10 boy Moritz come in
thin boy Cruiser club then boy Cruiser
club well now honey that would sell them
start a company thin boy Cruiser Club
where do you buy just biked around
manases cruise around guys
I'll be around I'll be out there I'll be
out there man I'll see out there you
guys got it this one kid route